hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing Hogwarts
lovable gamekeeper Hagrid what do we
really know about rubius Hagrid The
Towering half giant seemed to be a
simple content groundskeeper but when we
look back over the years Hagrid's life
was filled with tragedy and all sorts of
challenges starting at the very
beginning today we're going to unpack
Hagrid's life taking a look at the highs
lows and everything in between but
before we get too deep into the
in-universe aspects of Hagrid's life I
thought I'd first Enlighten you with a
few little-known factoids about the
inspiration behind Hagrid's character
the list of Harry Potter characters
inspired by real people is lengthy
including Severus Snape Harry Potter Ron
Weasley and even gilderoy Lockhart to
name a few so it shouldn't come as a
surprise to you that just like these
other characters Hagrid 2 was based on a
real person about biker to be precise in
Harry Potter page to screen the complete
filmmaking Journey according to Robbie
Coltrane the character was modeled on a
real biker Coltrane said that JK Rowling
told him that Hagrid was based on Hell's
Angels she knew in the west country he
was just huge and terrifying Coltrane
recalled Rowling telling him and then he
would sit down and talk about his garden
and how his petunias had been very bad
that year
Rowling also supplied some interesting
information pertaining to hankrid's name
revealing that just like many other
characters in the story his name was
very carefully chosen Hagrid is a big
drinker who's regularly seen by Harry to
indulge in visits to the pub and even
getting inebriated his name alludes to
his personality trait because rubius is
related to the word Ruddy which means
reddish and is apparent on someone who
drinks a lot parents like with anyone's
origin story akrid's life would never
have come to be had it not been for his
parents Hagrid's parentage was a pretty
poorly kept secret to most it seemed
obvious that he was born from a mixed
relationship between a giant ass and a
wizard still Hagrid tried to keep the
details a secret at times although he
never quite fooled anyone his mother was
known as Fred welfare since we don't
have the clearest records we can't be
sure when she was born but fruit welfare
must have been at least few decades old
when she gave birth to Hagrid in 1928
like any other giant Fred welfare was
well over 20 feet tall and a force to be
reckoned with with a natural resistance
to most spells and curses it would have
taken over half a dozen Wizards to
defeat Hagrid's mother in a fight for
that reason the Wizarding World feared
giants like grid welfare most of all
which makes her marriage to Hagrid's
father all the stranger at some point
prior to Hagrid's birth in 1928 Fred
Walther first met Hagrid's dad the
historical records never revealed his
full name so we only know him as Mr
Hagrid although giantesses and men had
been known to Wed each other it wasn't a
very common practice as you could guess
Wizards and witches frowned upon mixed
marriages and even the Giants who valued
size and power Above All Else looked
down on their peers who married weak
human wizards but Fred wolfer and Mr
Hagrid actually gave their relationship
an honest attempt and they were happy
for a while mother's abandonment in
December of 1928 Fred wolfer and Mr
Hagrid welcomed their son rubius into
the world almost instantly red walther's
demeanor changed in giant culture they
prided themselves on having the largest
strongest babies and after a quick
glance at the infant rubius Fred wolfer
realized that she had failed as a half
giant rubius was a fraction of the size
of other giant babies and by the time
Hagrid was three years old it became
glaringly apparent that Hagrid would
never grow to the same size as other
Giants which caused Fred Wolfe's loyalty
to falter ashamed by her child's small
stature Fred wolfer decided to run away
and fled back to her giant Colony before
Hogwarts in the years it followed young
rubius Hagrid lived a simple life with
his father the pair lived in the west
country of England near near the forest
of Dane which is the cause for Hagrid's
distinctive accent hagra doesn't say
much about his old man but he seemed to
be an honest kind wizard before Hagrid
was even old enough to attend primary
school he had already grown six feet
tall often he would throw his father
over his shoulders and haul him around
the house and yard although Hagrid and
his father had a strong relationship
Hagrid's social life suffered outside of
the home as a half giant other parents
would often warn their children about
playing with him it wasn't until Hagrid
received his acceptance letter to
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry that the young boy thought he
could finally find a close-knit group of
friends his first wand but before
embarking on his journey to Hogwarts
young Hagrid just like so many other
students before him made the Trek to
Diagon Alley specifically ollivanders
where he would receive his first wand it
seems strange that for as long as we've
known Hagrid he's held an umbrella in
place of wand and while Hagrid's
original one is inside of this umbrella
it was once a fully functioning magical
item in its own right Hagrid's first
wand free umbrella was a 16-inch Oak
wand rather bendy with an unknown core
material those with Oak ones usually
have an affinity with the magic of the
natural world a bendy wand signifies a
high level of adaptability in his
personality and the length of his wand
is representative of his large stature
and enormous personality for these
reasons Hagrid's wand seemed just about
perfect for him but the wand purchasing
process wasn't exactly straightforward
because it wasn't until after purchasing
the ones that Hagrid's magical powers
surfaced you see magical powers aren't
revealed in a magical child until they
are provoked out of them sometimes
remaining dormant for a considerable
amount of time in Hagrid's case he was a
late bloomer in that his powers didn't
truly manifest until after he'd received
his Hogwarts letter and purchased his
first wand from ollivanders this can be
partially attributed to the fact that
Hagrid simply never had an incident in
his childhood where his emotions were
heightened without the proper stimulus
his powers simply didn't manifest
unfortunately however his powers did
start to appear just before embarking on
his journey at Hogwarts in 1940 Hagrid
began his first semester at Hogwarts
School following his arrival at the
school Hagrid made his way to the
Sorting ceremony which in his case has
proven to be a topic of contention
amongst fans though there has been much
speculation over the years and a
considerable number of theories it turns
out that rather unsurprisingly Hagrid
was a part of Gryffindor given Hagrid's
bravery kindness nobility this probably
isn't much of a shock and while his
house is not revealed in the books it is
revealed in an article published on
Wizarding World that makes this little
factoid Canon the prospect of attending
Hogwarts was quite Bittersweet for
Hagrid while attending Hogwarts would
provide the opportunity to meet other
magical children and expand his magical
Horizons it also meant that he would
have to leave behind his beloved father
hackgrid also quickly realized that in
some aspects Hogwarts wasn't all too
different from The Real World at school
he continued to suffer as his fellow
students ridiculed and bullied him if he
were anyone else he'd use his natural
Brawn to turn the tide against his
bullies but Hagrid's low self-esteem and
non-violent disposition made him a
natural Target
this caused Hagrid to instead search for
companionship through magical beasts and
creatures showcasing very early on his
affinity for the natural world and the
creatures within it however this hobby
did land Hagrid in trouble on more than
a few occasions as a student Hagrid
raised werewolf Cubs under his bed Trott
off into the Forbidden Forest to
wrestled trolls and even acquired an
acromantula that would heavily impact
Hagrid's future
by his third year at school Hagrid had
grown to nearly 11 feet in height but
unfortunately he continued to struggle
socially to make matters worse Hagrid's
father Mr Hagrid suddenly passed
eventually Tom Riddle who was only a few
years older than Hagrid at the time
decided to frame Hagrid for a recent
murder the school riddle was actually
the one responsible for the crime but he
managed to convince the ministry of
magic that one of Hagrid's dangerous
pets and Acro Manchester named aragog
was the culprit in the aftermath Hagrid
was expelled from Hogwarts and forbidden
by the ministry from using a wand ever
again however thanks to Albus
Dumbledore's quick intervention Hagrid
was saved from going back into the real
world as an orphan Dumbledore managed to
land Hagrid a role studying how to
become a groundskeeper
this gesture of kindness might have been
enough to keep Hagrid from a life of
crime with his father figure gone the
young half giant had nowhere to turn and
the fate of giants in The Wizarding
World was usually a bloody painful one
Official Game Keeper so as the years
passed Hagrid grew and grew under
Dumbledore's watchful eye rubius lived a
peaceful life with each passing semester
The Faculty entrusted the young half
giant with more responsibilities until
eventually he was promoted to head
groundskeeper sometime before 1967
succeeding the previous groundskeeper
OGG Hagrid's role went by many titles
gamekeeper grandkeeper and keeper of
keys on any given day Hagrid could be
seen securing the Hogwarts grounds from
Intruders or dropping down pine trees to
decorate the Great Hall for Christmas
dinner but the part Hagrid loved the
most was tending to the magical beasts
that Hogwarts raised first Wizarding
the years passed faster and by the 1970s
rubius Hagrid found himself quickly
becoming a senior member of the staff at
Hogwarts but that wasn't what he
remembered most about those years the
1970s was the start of Lord Voldemort's
first campaign against the ministry a
conflict known as the first Wizarding
War for the next 10 years Hagrid
Faithfully served Albus Dumbledore and
the Order of the Phoenix as they fought
against Voldemort and his Death Eaters
during this time Hagrid's loyalty
bravery and unwavering determination
Shone through like a lumos spell in the
darkest of nights alongside Dumbledore
and other members Hagrid clandestinely
worked to thwart Voldemort's plans and
protect the innocent whether it was
gathering valuable information or aiding
in covert operations Hagrid played a
vital role in the resistance against the
Dark Lord's rise to power when the dark
wizard finally fell in his failed
assassination of Harry Potter
Hagrid was dispatched to retrieve the
infant and return him to safety Hagrid
under orders from Dumbledore himself
flew to the ruined Cottage in godrics
Hollow to retrieve baby
harrying him in his massive arms Hagrid
placed the boy who lived with his muggle
relatives the dursleys providing him
with a chance to grow up away from the
spotlight of his Fame
no sir house was almost destroyed but I
got out all right before the Muggles
started swarming around he fell asleep
as we were flying over Bristol
acromantula injury between that fateful
night and the next time Hagrid would see
Harry Potter very little changed in the
half Giant's life he continued to work
as the gamekeeper at Hogwarts tending to
the Aging castle and the creatures who
lived there at one point while wandering
around the Forbidden Forest Hagrid's
love of the tarantula-like acromantula
nearly cost him his life one of the
creatures bit Hagrid and injected enough
Venom to overwhelm his enhanced immune
system after a short stay in hospital
Hagrid was back on his feet and returned
to the Forbidden Forest to spend time
with those creatures once more
reconnecting with Harry in 1991 Hagrid
ventured through England to find Harry
Potter's last known location at that
time his adoptive parents the dursleys
refused to send and the boy to Hogwarts
hoping to find a secluded home where not
even Albus Dumbledore could find them
Potter and the dursleys ended up on a
tiny Island appropriately named Hut on
the rock it wasn't long before Hagrid
tracked Harry down though and after a
brief shouting match with Harry's Uncle
the half giant took Potter on his very
first Adventure in The Wizarding World
acting as Harry's guide Hagrid
introduced Harry to the enchanting world
of wizards while escorting him to the
bustling streets of Diagon Alley and the
legendary leaky cauldron in Diagon Alley
a place brimming with wonders Hagrid
ensured that Harry acquired all the
Necessities for his education the first
stop was Gringotts Wizarding Bank there
they delved into the depths of The
Potter's Vault retrieving much-needed
funds to support Harry's journey through
Hogwarts and what's a birthday without a
thoughtful gift Hagrid surprised Harry
with Hedwig a magnificent snowy white
owl who would become Harry's Law
companion throughout his magical
Endeavors he also reassured Harry
comforting him about his imminent
attendance at Hogwarts with the gentle
smile he handed Harry a ticket
meticulously detailing the date time and
place where Harry would board the
legendary Hogwarts Express it was a
ticket to not only a magical train but
to take it to a lifetime of wondrous
experiences and Unforgettable
friendships just like many male role
models in Harry's life Hagrid quickly
became one of the boy's most important
father figures especially in Harry's
early years when he suffered as an
outcast Hagrid was always around to lend
an ear Azkaban but after Harry returned
to the Wizarding World so did another
Force Lord Voldemort and he was
desperate to take on true physical form
at first he attempted to steal the
Philosopher's Stone at one point his
accomplice in the pursuit Professor
Quirrell managed to dupe Hagrid into
revealing how to get around Hogwarts
newest security measure a three-headed
dog the very next year Hagrid got in
more trouble when messages appeared on
Hogwarts wall claiming that the Chamber
of Secrets was once again opened with
the original reason for Hagrid's
expulsion fresh on everyone's mind the
ministry quickly determined Hagrid was
the villain behind everything and sent
him to Azkaban to rot away after Harry
Potter discovered the truth and
destroyed but the Basilisk and the Diary
of Tom Riddle the ministry allowed
Hagrid to return a professor as the
years between the Battle of Hogwarts
grew shorter and shorter Harry Potter's
list of mentors and allies grew longer
and longer once Hagrid was perhaps the
most important figure in the young
Wizard's life but that would all change
although not all change was bad for
Hagrid by Harry's third year Hagrid
became a professor taking on teaching
responsibilities for the care of magical
creature
the title of professor at Hogwarts was
quite an impressive feat compared to
Hagrid's own classmates who had actually
graduated from Hogwarts the half giant
actually ended up as one of the most
accomplished the next year when the
trial was a tournament concluded and
Voldemort took on a new body Hagrid was
assigned a particularly tough task by
the Order of the Phoenix fearing that
the Giants might once again align
themselves with Voldemort in the dark
Wizards Hagrid went to their secret
colonies to bring them to his side the
mission seemed like it might actually
succeed but on one of the very first
Nights At The Colony a giant aligned
with dark Wizards killed the ruling
Chieftain and turned the tribe away from
Hagrid and Dumbledore's Alliance
Hagrid's time with the Giants wasn't an
entire failure though as he discovered
one of his few living relatives a
brother named grop Hagrid returned to
Hogwarts keeping his brother's existence
a secret in the Forbidden Forest but his
time there short-lived when Dolores
Umbridge took over Albus Dumbledore's
position Hagrid was forced out his Exile
didn't last long though as Dumbledore
eventually returned but the months that
followed continued with conflict after
conflict it all culminated with the
battle of the astronomy Tower where
Severus Snape killed Albus Dumbledore
through a torrent of Tears Hagrid
carried the old Wizard's body at his
funeral laying him to rest as the latest
victim of Voldemort's new war Hagrid
would be placed in a similarly Grim
scenario the following year when Harry
Potter fought against Voldemort and
nearly died while Harry was in limbo
Hagrid carried the lifeless corpse just
as he had done for Dumbledore this time
though Potter managed to come back to
life and finish the fight against
Voldemort striking him dead during the
Battle of Hogwarts which brings me to my
next Point what happened to Hagrid after
Voldemort's all after the Deathly
Hallows at the end of the battle of
Hogwarts many lives were lost and apart
from the brief epilogue in the last book
film ended we weren't given much more
info with regards to what exactly
happened to most of the surviving
characters we see Harry Jenny Hermione
Ron Malfoy and more sending their
children after Hogwarts at platform nine
and three quarters but Hagrid is nowhere
to be seen so what came of the gentle
giant where did Hagrid go when the chaos
ended and all of the Dust settled as
much as I love Sirius Black Hagrid was
in my eyes Harry's true Father Figure he
was there for him right from the
beginning of his life and carefully
watched over him as he grew from a young
boy to a young man Hagrid was the one
who introduced Harry to The Wizarding
World he showed him the ropes and he
even bought Harry Hedwig he's also the
one that grabbed Harry from The Potter
residents and brought him to Private
Drive interior eyed as he left Harry on
the dursley's doorstep with no close
family relationships in his life a
father that died and a mother that left
Harry was all Hagrid hand and Hagrid's
care for Harry was shown in his actions
and behavior throughout the series
after the Wizarding war ended many
people were left uncertain of their next
course of action as many of the people
they knew and loved had died though the
good guys emerged Victorious Hogwarts
was in shambles and many relationships
had been severed Hagrid's closest
relationships were with Harry Dumbledore
and the school and both the school at
least temporarily and Dumbledore were
down for the count so what did Hagrid do
next well it turns out that Hagrid
simply continued working at Hogwarts in
his usual posting the only thing that
Hagrid loved more than Hogwarts was his
love of magical creatures which explains
why you would choose to continue on as a
professor for the care of magical
creatures at the school Hagrid is also
referenced in the epilogue by Harry
while speaking to his son Albus by Al
said Harry as his son hugged him don't
forget hagras invited you to tea next
Friday don't mess with peeves don't duel
anyone till you've learned how and don't
let James wind you up the Apple log of
Harry Potter gave us a glimpse of 19
years into the future which would make
the year 2017 and Hagrid 89 years old
however thanks to the longevity of
wizard kind I'm sure that Hagrid was
still very sprightly in addition to
teaching at Hogwarts it's been suggested
that Hagrid may have at one point
further pursued their relationship with
Madame Maxime however the two eventually
proved to be too different to make
things work
we don't have much more info on the
gentle half giant other than this but I
hope this gives you some closure with
regards to Hagrid's character and that's
it for this video did you know much
about Hagrid's life his Beginnings what
video do you want next be sure to leave
a comment down below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live